the all right good morning everyone
Committee of conference on House Bill
welcome so you didn't like our
Amendment that's
correct the um the limit that's
included
um is first of all it's way too
low and secondly
it's it's not going to work at least
partly because a recovery house needs to
be in a dent section where the people
involved who probably don't have cars or
licenses can get around can get to
jobs um you couldn't do it in Epsom you
might be able to do it in downtown
Pittsfield or down Town Allen toown
because they have facilities but you're
not going to get uh recovery houses out
bonies so that's that's not going to
US senator Murphy you were probably the
most vocal in the Senate I was thank you
um the difficulty is and having
employed a large number of people who
reside in these recovery homes in the
past um you know these are very critical
facilities we definitely need more of
them but they carry a a
consequence these homes reasonably have
rules residents can't come in drunk they
can't come in high they can't fight they
can't steal there's a curfew and if they
break the rules they're shown the
door and when they're shown the door
often they end up
homeless
and in
Manchester the residents and the
businesses have faced a severe impact
for the quality of life and when this
bill came
forward uh I did some research and found
that Manchester and Nashville combined
have approximately a thousand recovery
beds the rest of the state combined has
about
300 um so you know this includes
beds Berlin Salem Dairy Portsmith you
know these are areas that have the
density that you're speaking of I
understand that many of the residents
don't have cars some do but a lot do not
and they may need a walkable community
and I understand that EPA may not be the
ideal location for them although to be
fair goof toown does have a facility um
with 12 beds so you know smaller
communities can support them um but it
is not fair nor right that two
cities carries the Lion Share of these
facilities in my opinion so that is why
the amendment was drafted the way it was
and that is why the limit is set where
it is where Nashville and Manchester
basically Nash is 100 beds over the
limit if if one bed for every 200 and 50
residents isn't the proper number then
let's talk about where the number should
be but that's a
pretty you know
420 468 beds in Manchester right now 475
in nashaa it's a lot of beds it's a lot
of people that are
facing they
they I truly wish the best for them I I
hope they get better we need more
facilities but these communities can
only take so much
well Manchester is close to 10% of the
state's population so you would expect a
significant number of of effort there I
I don't disagree with the math except
that 10% and you know 44% give or take
of the beds a it doesn't really match up
so we have to spread these are critical
facilities I advocate for spreading the
communities thank you have nashor or
Manchester come in saying that they need
this legislation and that they've
overburden they're overburdened by beds
I had a conversation with the mayor of
Manchester he told me he supported the
legislation as as
amended um I've talked to my colleagues
in
nasua uh one of whom supported the
not follow I'll follow up please if I
can follow up I understand the mayor
have may have a position is there a
position taken from the board of Mayor
and
Alderman it was mayj he did not indicate
he was speaking for the entire Board of
Alder thank you madam chair I as I look
at this from a practical
standpoint the by
pushing these facilities out into rural
parts of the state where the
participants will have no no access to
the facility because they can't get
there they don't have cars they can't
there's no public
transportation uh it it sets it up for a
program that's going to fail uh and I
think that's that's not smart on our
part to to to set up failure before we
even start so these these facilities
need to be in urban areas that people
can walk to or take public
transportation
to representative do you believe that
marac dairy Salem London dery uh
Portsmouth Hampton Milford any of these
may be able to sustain
facilities in in most cases no I know I
can tell you from London der uh there is
no public transportation and in order to
get from from wherever they're residing
to to their counseling sessions uh
they'd have to take uh taxis or other
other forms of uh private transportation
that would be too expensive and and not
uh and and
just cause the uh individual not to show
up or not to not to
participate if that logic is true then
how come bosan has 47 beds Littleton has
42 beds lonia has 65 beds these are
communities that have stepped up and and
done their share to help the rest of the
state with this critical need but Salem
has
sir another point to consider is this
only applies to
registered or certified recovery
homes and if you put a limit on
registered or certified recovery homes
what you're going to get is
unregistered recovery
homes which are probably not as well-run
as the certified ones in
general I would agree with that Madam
share but there is room for 3,000
additional beds under the limit
Statewide
that any else sen Department SC we
haven't heard from you you have anything
you want to talk
about you know I think all these points
have been well made I you know the
intent of this bill is to make sure
that we are not there are no unnecessary
barriers to set a recovery houses right
because we know that these are an
important tool for people in recovery I
think the point about public
transportation is well taken I also
think the point about these being
available in many parts of the state is
important because whether they're on
public transportation or not we do know
that um there are people in recovery all
over the state that said unfortunately
um and we had this discussion in
committee continue to believe that you
know this amendment may not be the best
way to to accomplish that I mean I do
think more education is needed I think
that um easing the zoning which is is
done in the version passed by the house
could lead to other places sharing this
burden I mean you know I think that's
the intent and so um by by capping it
artificially in the amendment and
especially by the addition of the
affirmative vote of the legislative body
I just think um we're we're
unfortunately creating exactly the kind
of barriers that
that um that we that we don't want to
have and so to the extent that there are
people who need recovery homes I think
we want to make them available and that
is the intent of the bill and so
unfortunately um I T I tend to agree
one I guess I'm the only one that has an
offer an opinion yet uh Senator Murphy
certainly you know was uh took the lead
you know in the senate committee um but
you know for years and years and years
we hear Manchester NASA whatever come in
and say you know we're providing these
services but we're providing it for the
whole state because people who need the
services come to
us uh safe stations is one of the
examples uh four years ago five years
ago we passed the bill and we gave NASA
X number of million dollarss million and
a half or whatever it was uh but then
they decided to discontinue the thing
but still wanted the million and a half
dollars okay um I hear from the people
who go to jail and other things that uh
the farther they are from their uh
individual family and their Network that
supports them or causes them their
problem in some cases maybe uh you know
that it affects their recovery so there
are competing you know things here
um I guess what I would suggest and
that's if Senator Murphy is agreeable to
it that
uh you know since he's the the most
outspoken U proponent of the Senate side
and you or someone on your group get
together and see if you can't work out a
meeting
um but I suppose that's the timing is
going to be very difficult but uh then
we'll off with two options and we find
it difficult to support yours and you're
finding it difficult to support ours I
think that is the case one of the
two you know is it better to have one of
uh well
we're people we've been working with in
The Recovery House business are
convinced that the limit would be
intolerable so we and they would rather
have nothing so that's that's that's the
house
position well I'll leave it open for you
if you guys want
to you know recess for a while or
whatever and talk to Senator Murphy
whatever leave it open for the the only
thing I would say to Senator Murphy is
that if we clarify the zoning
issues we might be able to get some of
these other municipalities to step up
and encourage recovered houses this came
because the city of Lebanon discovered
their zoning was an issue and they were
confused and they needed to have it
clearer in order to support the recovery
houses they
wanted uh that may be the issue in Salem
OR Port Smith or
wherever and so I would like to suggest
that we try and see if clarifying that
encourages recovery homes to be located
municipalities again I if if I'm only
talking about dense municipalities you
know I can go right down through you
know Manchester Nashua uh conquer Dober
Rochester uh dairy uh I think it's Dairy
that you know the list of by population
no and I haven't haven't named anything
north of conquer yet well okay the thing
is that it's not necessarily the number
of people in a town although that helps
what it is is to have a center
as I said you know downtown Pittsfield
has a supermarket and clusters of
businesses it's not it's feasible to get
there without a
call and there are undoubtedly other
small towns in the state that have old
uh old centers that are that
are that are reasonable for this sort of
thing Littleton has a couple of recovery
houses Franklin has a couple
because they have
the back when a town of 3,000 people had
a downtown and so they've got clustered
housing and clustered
jobs well um why don't the Senators CAU
Us in another room and
but all right you can use the uh real
office
you go right
unlocked
e
I know that Senator Perkins coko wants
to speak and I think Senator Mur may
speak um yeah thank you for giving us to
a minute to iner I mean I I do think
there's some potential compromise here I
think your point representative about
this bill being needed for exactly the
reasons that concern Senator Murphy is
is wellmade and well taken you know this
bill as amended by the house may lead to
other places seeing additional recovery
houses um pop up and so you know I think
it's an important public policy for that
reason that said you know I think there
there could be some compromise made um
with Senator Murphy's position if you if
you guys are willing but um I think it's
an important BT I think we should try to
alive I'm willing to discuss compromise
in as far as the limit or as far as the
um affirmative vote by legislative body
of the
municipality um you know my position
isn't set in stone but I can't in good
faith and frankly out of obligation to
my constituents support the house
position as it currently stands so the
question for the my counterparts is are
you willing to
move that's the
question
no okay all right we will disagree and
um thank you for coming and and sharing
we will will undoubtedly be dealing with
this in the future ma'am if you think
that there's any wiggle room you can
certainly recess it and we would try to
come back back but it's up to you I
don't think